hey guys I know you're here for the
video so I'm gonna make this really fast
we had someone drop out of our cast
which is the reason we only have one guy
in this episode but honestly we want to
do the best job possible about any you
the best cast with an array of opinions
so if you want to be in our videos make
sure you sign up at jublee Mediacom /
casting and of course when you read all
your applications all your stories enjoy
the video guys
my dad cheat on my mom and mom cheated
on my dad my sister would always get
cheated on my brother cheated on his
wife I never thought that I would cause
that kind of pain to someone I am a
cheater and it was a very hard time in
my life when it happened I ruined the
entire part of myself before I wasn't
very empathetic with cheaters but after
I did it I understand I feel like it's a
part of me but it's not who I am right
now
they'd saved my early 20s I didn't know
why I was cheating I didn't think of a
bunch about it normally a lot of people
they definitely beat themselves up for
it I kind of I don't there for it I was
there for the cheating like let me tell
you like I'm here for it
it took a Tharsis it's cool for like the
moments while you're in it and then
afterwards I felt horrible it's like
okay I'm doing this I feel good because
I'm connecting with someone and I'm not
connecting with my partner and so this
feels good to have this sort of
connection with someone else I cheated
in another country so at that time I was
like oh nobody's gonna know about this I
don't say anything it's you know this is
all it's all about me right now so at
that time I enjoyed it but yeah as soon
as I got back I just felt so guilty man
you know you hi and then they went like
low yeah I enjoyed it in the process
because one my boyfriend at the time was
two thousand miles away
and here's my best friend's cousin who
is right here and open and willing and I
was like [ __ ] let's go
I would I actually cheated on somebody I
was in a long-distance relationship I
didn't cheat on the person like do sex
it was something totally different I
just considered other things that's
cheating I did not enjoy it no it was
like with a friend from like middle
school he like hit me up it was like huh
okay let's go hang out what's happening
um so no I didn't enjoy it and like you
didn't enjoy like actually being with
the person not at all from the man I
just I just like if you like let things
happen I just let it happen I'm just
like no really then why don't you stop
why didn't you why didn't you say
I don't want to do this thing yeah that
might feel like my lips outside gotta go
like you know he was like my ride I
couldn't yeah I would say I strongly
disagree with the saying simply because
people change people grow up people
learn things just because I did this one
bad thing when I was like let's say 15
doesn't mean that I should haunt me for
the rest of my adulthood what did you do
I was a cheater okay no not really
I've been in several long-term
relationships were like I've cheated
from the very beginning and to the very
end of their relationship you guys are
saying like I - - one time I was 15 or
something like that I'm like oh you guys
are awesome I was like on some
straight-up [ __ ] like straight up
so um like what I was doing wasn't truly
who I was I was a defense mechanism
I have these strong emotions towards my
partner I really wish that they would
listen to me they're not and so I'm just
going to go and do something that makes
me feel better so I don't think that
once a cheater always a cheater but I do
on the other hand always tell every
partner that I've been with about my my
habits and what I've done in the past I
share it openly because I think it's
something that should be that should be
shared more often because we're not the
only people that cheat people watching
this stuff or also cheaters
[Music]
three two one go just because a simple
fact that I told my boyfriend at the
time that I cheated on him and then he
forgave me but then these things are
happening where he's oh boy like what's
up where you going I'm going to parties
the oh boys are gonna be there huh I'm
just like why would you do that but just
makes me want to like just go back to
what I was doing like I can't face or
trust ya exactly the trust I trust after
was gone like oh I'm fine we're fine
like no we're not because you're not
emotionally mentally like oh I'm like
we're done right it wasn't done so after
that I broke up with him and I was like
no I'm not gonna be that person just
like okay cheated by I'm not gonna be
like that mentally or physically I'm
just gonna be like no we're gonna work
this out if it was the other way around
I still would have been banging at his
knees to be with me because of how much
I was in love with him and I still
forgive him for what he's done to me and
if anybody were to do that later on I'd
be like hey I've done it to a three out
of the four relationships I was in I
cheat was a cheater but on that one that
last one I got cheated on cheating all
throughout that first year second year
same thing through that I forgave him
for all of it I was still the one
begging him to be with me I've like
tried I said I forgave and forgot it for
that but I didn't really I still have I
still have a lot of hate in my heart for
that but what I let the next person do
that how the [ __ ] hell like what do
you mean I'm gonna get to know you just
for you to do all of that stuff like
that's why we learn from our past
mistakes which that's kind of me being a
hypocrite because I did the same mistake
over and over again oh you changed yeah
before I cheated I would have actually
been all the way back there and then I
came here because I just I'm I hold
grudges so I mean I will be more
understanding to a person if they
cheated on me because I did it but it
would be very hard for me to let it go
because I would always play it and
replay it in my head for me actually the
person I cheated on we're still together
we're getting married next month
it's an ask about
yeah so he forgave me big-time ah
obviously so you to give him long like
overseas yes at first I was just like
okay I'm gonna just break it off not say
anything but he was so willing to fix
whatever was going on and he was like I
don't know what's going on how what can
I do fix it I was like this is just what
I'm what's going on this is what I have
in my head like I'm not happy I think we
should go to counseling and stuff and so
we did and we like we're more honest and
open with each other and we were able to
like work it out it's not always wrong
because what if that person that you
relationship with is like toxic you're
just like okay I have like an excuse to
cheat on this person that's why it was
the break-up with the person I know but
like you thought but you still have
benefits with that person too you know
I'm saying like you're in this
relationship and you know like you have
benefits so hard right it's like this is
one of the things I'm like of why I'm
afraid of marriage it's like in some
ways it's like what if [ __ ] goes like
super self and like I can't just undo
this this is not just a breakup I am a
firm believer that no matter how toxic
somebody is no matter how horrible
somebody can be I don't think anybody on
this planet deserves to be cheated on I
wanted to believe I had good reason but
I didn't even though he called me a dumb
[ __ ] every other sentence and I was the
most ugly and stupid person that he's
ever met and I only exists to send him
nudes like yeah you did the right thing
we're getting out of there
[Music]
so the reason why I'm strongly disagree
is because if you actually let's love
someone why would you ever want to
inflict any sort of pain on them since
you're supposed to be there I guess you
can say their other half why would you
want to be the bad half of it it doesn't
really make any sense did you love the
guys that you cheated on no that's why
you didn't love them I don't love any of
them did you tell them that you love
them no you never said you look ILO I
never said it so any of them because I
didn't love them oh okay well that's
interesting I I mean I was in love with
the people I cheated on
I mean would you call yourself a selfish
person super selfish at that time you
for sure super super selfish I wish you
could have gone you've been selfish in a
different way and so not have hurt the
person exactly yeah I do I agree with
you I mean that's that's the thing that
now and this at this portion of life
like I try and I try and do I've not
cheated in a long while yeah I don't
have too many experience as a
relationship so actually my fiance he
was my first boyfriend so I feel like
you wanted to experience other other
people what was that so yeah like I said
he was my first relationship and at that
time like I wasn't very confident myself
my appearance my personality guys were
always looking at my friends you know
and I was like okay this guy likes me
it's like this is it you know and then
as I got older I just like more
comfortable with myself and I'm like out
when I was um in Japan I was like oh hey
people like I getting attention like I
love this like not like I fell out of
love with my fiance now but it was like
hey somebody else likes me I am pretty
like I am cool he's not just saying that
you know
[Music]
you guys I forgive you
I'd forgiven myself I for sure for sure
I mean it took a lot of like reflecting
I don't think my cheating was not is not
truly Who I am it was the result of of
not seeing healthy relationships as I
was growing up not seeing how people can
work through things in a healthy way I
feel like I had to forgive myself
just because especially after the
relationship that I was in after that I
got cheated on just because now I
understand both sides of it
it isn't easy both ways but I feel like
if you really actually want to learn and
grow from something you definitely have
to forgive yourself because you can't
grow if you don't forgive yourself
still haven't kind of forgiven myself
just a simple fact that we're kind of
like in a courtship so we're like
Intendant to get married so I could have
been in like her shoes of like Oh fiance
but I didn't get that chance just
because the simple fact that I cheated
and then all that stuff happened and
yeah that's something that I was like
damn this time if I egg would have
stayed I didn't cheat I could have been
like married by now I could have had
like the life that I wanted do you think
that you'd be like you and the guy would
still be together if you hadn't cheated
[Laughter]
well that's why I'm definitely still
working on it it's something that still
happened recently just last year so I
just felt like you know all my life I
grew up to be this perfect person my
parents are very proud of me I never
like went against them so when I went to
Japan we already engaged so me coming
back my dad already put money on a down
payment for the venue and stuff I felt
so guilty so like even now I just I know
everybody is like forgiving of me but I
just have to work on forgiving myself
still because I still think about it you
know how he affected everybody around me
[Applause]
once you cheated this is what teeters
look like where he came here I didn't
realize like I was like you guys